en la medida que pasan las semanas la
preocupación aumenta en esta región del
país en la región del donbass por la
crisis humanitaria provocada por la
guerra para empezar las rutas para
llegar hasta aquí son muchísimo más
malas las carreteras no están en buen
estado comparadas con otras del país a
esto se le suma la escasez de gasolina
lo que hace que sea muchísimo más
difíciles para los camiones abastecer a
esta provincia del país lo hemos visto
en algunos supermercados y también en
estaciones de gasolina donde
generalmente suele haber comida para
abastecer a quienes transitan por las
carreteras pues cada vez hay menos pero
esto se hace aún más difícil en esas
provincias que están atrapadas en medio
de la guerra además de la falta de la
gasolina llegar hasta allí se hace casi
imposible porque los enfrentamientos se
hacen cada vez mayores así que hace que
la preocupación por el futuro de estas
personas que están atrapadas allí en
medio de la guerra no solamente por lo
que les pueda pasar por los ataques por
la artillería por los bombardeos sino
también todo lo que pueda pasar no
tienen con qué comer